-It's nice to see you.
Thanks for coming in person.
-Jimmy, listen, this is a wee
gift from my son Daniel, who --
He and his business partner
started this tequila business
that's winning international
gold medals.
-I mean, yeah.
Take care, everybody.
Thank you. Bye-bye.
I say gracias. De Nada.
I know your son --
your other son is an actor.
-Michael. Yes, he is.
-Michael.
-Yeah.
-Is he enjoying it?
-You know, he's in the world
where, you know, I've told him
70% of actors are out of work
all the time.
This is true. I said,
"Welcome to the club, buddy."
-Yeah.
-But he's doing okay.
He's got a good presence.
-Yeah.
Well, I mean, coming from
you guys --
-But from his mother's side,
God rest her,
his mother's side of the family,
they go back
theatrically to the late 1700s.
-Wow. Is that right? Geez.
-So when he says it's in
his blood, it's in his blood.
-It's actually in his blood,
yeah, yeah.
I heard a rumor about you, I was
reading online -- a good one.
[ Laughter ]
That you may be doing a reboot
of "The Naked Gun."
-Yes, hopefully.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
-With Seth McFarlane.
Is he involved?
-Seth McFarlane is writing it
with his team.
He may direct it.
He was approached by Paramount
Studios, and they picked me.
[ Laughter ]
-How fun would that be?
I would be there tomorrow.
-Jimmy, it's either going to be
the end of my career or --
[ Laughter ]
-You know, we had
Brian Tyree Henry on the show.
And we were talking about you.
-Yes. He's a great actor.
-A talented guy, he's funny.
We were talking about --
He did a film with you.
We had a picture of you guys --
-The one film I was
totally miscast in.
-Oh, is that right?
-Totally miscast in this film.
-Why do you think
you were miscast?
-Because I saw it.
[ Laughter ]
You know, I made -- Up to
Christmas, I made 100 films.
I saw "Widows" --
this is the film with
Brian and myself in it.
Brian's terrific in it.
And I was almost in tears
I was so bad.
I was so miscast in that film.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-But you're never bad
in anything.
-I was bad in this.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow. Alright.
I was talking about your red
carpet you did before this film,
which made me laugh because I
go, "Liam's a great guy.
I mean, he's funny and he
doesn't take it too serious."
He goes, "Yeah," he goes, "What
were you doing here?"
And he goes, "We're were doing
Blue Steel."
-Oh, yeah.
-And I go,
"Wait, from 'Zoolander?'"
He's like, "Yeah.
We're taking photos
and Liam leans over and goes,
'Give him Blue Steel.'"
And I just thought it was
the funniest thing.
-Yeah, we all did.
-Do you always do Blue Steel?
-All the time. All the time.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-Are you a "Zoolander" fan?
-I loved "Zoolander."
-Me too.
-I loved it.
-Yeah.
-I was doing a film with
Chris Hemsworth
two or three years ago.
-Yeah.
-Three years ago.
And we had to pose for a couple
of photographs,
and I said my usual line.
I said, "Okay, they got that.
Let's do a Blue Steel."
And Chris went,
"I'm going to do a Magnum."
And I went, "Oh, okay."
[ Laughter ]
-That's funny.
That's very funny.
-So he was totally in on it.
-Yeah, because Magnum is
the same as Blue Steel.
-Pretty much.
[ Laughter ]
There's a very slight
difference.
-There's a slight difference.
Can you show everyone
the Blue Steel?
Could we give each other --
-Yeah, okay.
How far are you?
-Yeah, right here.
That, right there.
-Okay.
-Here we go. Blue Steel.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
Right now Ben Stiller
is freaking out
'cause that is the best thing
I've ever seen.
-Do you want to see the Magnum?
-Let's see the Magnum,
yeah, yeah.
Drum roll, can we get --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You see the difference?
-Yeah, I did.
Yeah, yeah,
I saw the difference.
I want to talk about
your new movie "Blacklight."
When you've been on the show,
I remember "Taken," when it --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, absolutely.
When that movie came out, you
were like, "Yeah, I don't know.
I was always -- I'll try
this action film thing."
You talked to Luc Besson.
You chased him down?
-Yeah. My wife was in --
They were showing her film
at the Shanghai Film Festival
and Luc was there.
Luc Besson. A wonderful man.
-Yeah.
-Terrific director, innovator.
-Anyway, he was head
of the jury.
And I had read this "Taken"
script and I thought,
"Well, it's going
straight to video,
but it's a cool --
it's a cool little story."
-It's a cool little story,
but it'll go straight to video?
-And it'll go straight to video,
and no one will see it,
but I get to fight a lot,
which I wanted to do.
So I met Luc and I said, "Luc,
I'm sure I'm not
on your list at all,
but I used to box as a kid
and I did sword fights
in a few movies,"
and I said, "I'd love the chance
to do this."
So push came to shove
and I got the part.
-Yeah.
-It was three months in Paris
working out with these stunt
guys five days a week.
It was terrific. I was like
a kid in a candy store.
And then I thought,
"Right, that's over.
It's going straight to video."
And my wife, God rest her,
when the film came out --
She always brought me a cup of
tea and a bran muffin
every morning
when I was at home.
So Sunday I hear her
coming up the stairs
with her tray,
giggling, laughing.
Something's up.
So she gives me the tea and the
bran muffin and she's giggling.
I said, "What's wrong?"
She said, "You won't believe it.
'Taken' is number --"
I think it was number two.
It came in number two
over the weekend.
Then the following week
it came in number three.
Then it moved up to
number two again,
and it hovered around there.
So it became a hit.
-Yeah, you think? Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
She was laughing. She was like,
"This movie you thought was
going to go straight to video."
-And not because of -- You know,
the writing was wonderful
and Pierre Morel, the director,
directed incredibly well.
It was a tight little
European thriller.
But I still thought it would go
straight to video.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And it went on to make like over
a billion dollars.
So congrats. I want to talk
about "Blacklight."
More with Liam Neeson
when we come back.
Stick around, everybody.